I'm Daemon Hatfield and this is IGN News.
Former Nintendo president Hiroshi Yamauchi died today.
He was 85.
Yamauchi  was the 3rd president of Nintendo, taking the position in 1949 while in his early 20s.
At that time, Nintendo was mostly manufacturing playing cards.
Under Yamauchi's leadership, the company entered the electronics market,...
...and became a global leader in the video game industry.
In the 70s, Nintendo started creating toys and opening amusement shooting galleries around Japan.
Yamauchi was almost 50 when Pong was released,...
...and he inked a deal to distribute home Pong machines.
The next step was for Nintendo to start creating its own video games,...
...which led to the Famicom and the Nintendo Entertainment System.
Yamauchi oversaw a time of incredible profit for Nintendo during the 8 and 16-bit eras,...
...although the company faced challenges and stiff competition during the 90s.
He was succeeded by current Nintendo president Satoru Iwata in 2002.
Yamauchi  continued to serve as a special adviser.
He retired at 75, but still came up with the idea for the Nintendo DS while serving as chairman of the board.
This is IGN News.